مرحباً ، كيف حالك ، نعم ، جيد جدًا ، دعنا
نفعل هذا ، نحن قذارة نركز على
القضاء على حوادث الطرق ، نستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي للتنبؤ
بهذه الحوادث ومنعها مثلك ، كما
نستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي أيضًا لتقليل عدد
الحوادث على الطريق الذي نعمل معه
تكتشف الشرطة بشكل أساسي متى
يتم تشتيت انتباه السائق في سيارة أخرى مثل
ما إذا كان على الهاتف أو يأكل أو
يشرب أو يرسل الرسائل النصية ، فما هي التحديات الرئيسية التي
نواجهها حتى الآن
هي في الواقع جمع البيانات
لأغراض التدريب سواء كان ذلك من أجل
إنها مهمة تستغرق وقتًا طويلاً أو بالنسبة للكاميرات ،
ولكنها
شيء يجب القيام به من أجل
تحسين دقة النظام الذي أعتقد
أنه كان لديك أيضًا مرحلة حيث
كان عليك جمع نموذج بيانات كامل في
حالتك  هناك شيء واحد يتبادر إلى الذهن هو أن
هناك الكثير من البيانات العامة ، فهناك
الكثير من الجامعات التي تجمع
البيانات وتنشرها عبر الإنترنت وسواء كان
ذلك في الصبي أو في أماكن أخرى
تعرفها.  لا يهتم نظامك حقًا
بالنظر فقط إلى الصور وصور البطاقة ،
لذا ربما يمكنك الاستفادة من بعض
قواعد البيانات هذه ، فهذا شيء مختلف
لأنك تحتاج إلى عرض من
الكاميرات ولكن في بعض الأحيان تجد حتى
الكاميرات العامة متاحة على الإنترنت لذا فهي
بيانات حقيقية  ويمكنك أيضًا استخدام هذه
المعلومات التي تحتوي على بيانات من
المركبات الآن عندما قلت إن
لديك غطاءًا تجريبيًا يقوم به رجال الشرطة ، لذا فهو
مصدر بيانات رائع لا أعتقد أنك
بحاجة إلى الكثير من البيانات التي تعرفها عن النظام
نفسه النظام  ستتحسن بمرور الوقت
ولكن البيانات نفسها إذا كانت تعمل عليها
يجب أن تكون مهمة ولكن بمجرد أن تصل
إلى مستوى ما ، يصبح السؤال حول
كيفية قياسها ولكن في البداية
يجب أن يكون نموذجك أكثر تركيزًا على التكنولوجيا
نفسها باستخدام البيانات التي جمعتها كيف
هل يمكنك زيادة الأداء إلى الحد الأقصى ، كيف
يمكنك جعله فعالًا قدر الإمكان
بقدر الإمكان ، وبعد ذلك مع
نمو الطيارين مع نمو الشراكات التي
تعرفها ، تصبح البيانات نفسها
تعرفها تقريبًا مثل AC  سوف يكون لديك
الكثير من البيانات إلى حيث يتم
نشر المزيد من البيانات سيكون لدينا
أفضل بالضبط ولكن
أعتقد أن الأساس هو ما يجب أن
تقلق بشأنه الآن كيف تتأكد من أنك من
أجل البيانات التي جمعتها  أو حتى
البيانات العامة هل أنت قادر على تحقيق
كل ما تحتاجه لتحقيق مؤشرات الأداء الرئيسية
تلك تلك الأهداف التي تحتاجها
لذلك أعتقد أنك تعلم أنك يجب أن
تركز على أي بيانات لديك
أداء لنظامك هو ما
أفعله  تحقيق أهدافي أعتقد أن
الفرصة هنا في الطريقة التي
تحاول بها الحكومة تطوير
اقتصاد المعرفة هذا في محاولة للبحث عن طريق
بعيدًا عن النفط لبناء صناعات
تمثل صناعات المستقبل والذكاء
الاصطناعي وأنت تعرف النقل المستقل
والتقنيات ذات الصلة  هو جزء
من المستقبل كما قلت ، ليس في كل مكان
تعمل فيه الشركات الناشئة مع
وكالة حكومية كبيرة سواء كانت هيئة الطرق والمواصلات
سواء كانت شرطة دبي سواء
كانت الحكومة في Y تقدم
في نظام بيئي صحي للغاية
، تجلب بيئة للشركات الناشئة الأكثر مرونة
تقنية جديدة
إلى السوق لمنحهم أساسًا مجالًا
للاختبار وعندما ينجحون في
إضافة قيمة وإنقاذ الأرواح وجعل
الناس أكثر راحة وسعادة يكونون
على اتصال بهم  ليس في
كل مكان يمكنك فيه الحصول على هذه
الفرصة للذهاب على ما يرام ، شكرًا لك يا جو
على الرحلة والأفكار ، نعم كان من
الرائع التحدث إليك حظًا سعيدًا ، شكرًا
لك